Hey what's up guys my name is The Cherno and
welcome to an entirely new series!
Ray Tracing.The series is Ray Tracing.
This is both somethingthat has been requested a lot and also something
that I've always personally really wanted to do
so I'm happy that I finally have found the time
to be able to sit down and do this. Now this video
is going to be kind of like an introduction we are
going to actually write some code and make some
pixels appear and iI'll introduce you to basically
all the tools that we'll be using however we're
not going to be getting into anything too deep
today which is actually a good thing because
i'm going to give you all a bunch of resources
materials prerequisites everything so that you
can kind of prepare and also work along with
what we'll be doing without having to necessarily
wait for me all the time to post new videos those
of you who don't know i'm developing a game engine
called hazel that tends to take some time out of
my day so i'm going to try my best for the series
to be consistent okay so what exactly are we doing
here what are we going to be building building a
ray tracer is an extremely vague statement because
a ray tracer could be something that you could get
done like in a couple days in a weekend knowing
nothing about it or it could be as large as
something like renderman which is used to render
like all of the pixar movies arnold v-ray you know
all of those other renderers whilst i don't think
we're going to quite achieve the latter we are
going to in fact broaden the scope beyond a basic
ray tracer so step one obviously is going to be
something fairly simple we're going to be starting
by looking at the ray tracing in one weekend book
series by peter shirley these are fantastic and
honestly i think that if you are wanting to learn
about ray tracing you should definitely start
there what i'm going to be doing is essentially
following this book series implementing it here in
video form explaining everything myself changing
quite a few things and making this more of like
a real-time application rather than something that
just writes pixels to a file but the actual source
content is going to be very similar to those books
we'll also be going further than that and actually
implementing something that can render triangles
triangles of course are very important because
we need triangles to be able to render 3d meshes
the inspiration for this series came from me doing
code review videos on my channel you may have seen
a few it was extremely common for me to actually
receive ray traces people had built however they
were exceptionally slow a little status update
i've been sitting here for about a minute this is
this is taking this is taking some serious time
why is it so slow it's rendering nothing well i
mean they weren't all exceptionally slow but i
didn't see anything anywhere close to real-time
interactive performance and frame rates which is
something that we're going to be exploring a ray
tracer running in real time yes it's possible
these days in those code review videos a lot
of you like the fact that i actually optimized
the code and talked a lot about optimization so
that is one of the reasons why this series here
exists i'm going to be hopefully teaching you
how you can optimize your code a little bit more
using these ray traces is kind of like the the
examples the guinea pigs c plus is of course
language we'll be using for this series sorry rust
people however once we get all this up and running
in a generally like good and optimized fashion
in c plus plus we're going to be taking it to the
next level and moving it to the gpu using vulcan
that of course is going to be like a major kind
of project and development and it is much more
realistic these days obviously to use the gpu for
such tasks as ray tracing this isn't going to be
like an rtx kind of real time-ish tutorial it's
actually going to be like a proper ray tracer
which will eventually become a path tracer that
can render like arbitrary scenes hopefully with
photo realism with the end goal of integrating
this into the hazel engine so yeah this is a
pretty serious project anyway hopefully you are
all as excited as i am but where do we begin what
do you need to know to be able to actually follow
along with this series so first and foremost we
will be using c plus if you don't know c plus i
actually have a series on my channel where i teach
c plus hey what's up guys my name is echeno and
welcome to a brand new series this series is
going to teach you everything you need to know
about c plus plus it's not the only way to learn
c plus but it's not bad we'll be using windows
and visual studio for this project however it's
c plus plus and we're not going to be using any
windows api like explicit things so it should
be portable and run across all platforms but
if you're not using windows you're gonna have to
figure out how to get it to compile and build on
your own for your platform you don't need to be an
expert in c plus plus i'm going to be explaining
every line of code that i write and besides
it's not really going to be about c plus of
course we're going to be talking about ray tracing
the algorithms that go into that all of the math
that you need you know that kind of stuff will
be covered so the programming language doesn't
even really matter that much but if you are
familiar with programming in some respect at least
that will be a huge help the next thing that is
extremely important arguably more important than
the first thing is math turns out mathematics is
pretty important now i'm going to try my best to
explain like all the math stuff that we actually
use and cover however i'm not going to explain
like what a vector is and all those related
operations like the dot and the cross product
i assume that you know all of that if you do not
then you'll have to do some homework now as far
as where to learn math i highly recommend that you
take a look at brilliant they've also been amazing
enough to sponsor this series the kind of math
that we'll actually be looking at everything from
algebra to actual geometry stuff all of that is
actually covered by brilliant and brilliant being
brilliant i mean i can't like you really need to
actually try this out for yourself to see what i'm
talking about but the great thing about brilliant
is that unlike other like course platforms it
actually has extremely engaging and interactive
courses the best way to learn all this mathematics
and ray tracing stuff is by practice you need to
actually do the work yourself now i don't know
about you and to be fair everyone is different but
i'm an extremely visual learner that means that
if you're talking to me about vectors for example
you need to show me a vector i need to be able to
visualize a vector in some form because if i can
see it it just makes more sense to me and that's
what i love about brilliant the fact that they do
have a lot of visual content a lot of interactive
content they ask you questions they quiz you they
keep you actively engaged so that you actually
learn in the most efficient way possible now if
you already know all the math that goes into ray
tracing and you don't need to revise it you might
be interested in some of brilliant other courses
they have courses on computer science physics
data structures that kind of stuff one of the best
things about brilliant is that you can actually
get started for free right now just click my link
in description below however brilliant have been
nice enough to offer 20 off an annual membership
for the first 200 subscribers who sign up using
that link in the description below definitely
sign up explore some of their amazing courses for
yourself you really have to actually go through
them to see what i'm talking about and it's
honestly a fantastic way to revise all the math
that you'll need for this series huge thank you
to brilliant for sponsoring this video once you've
got all the math stuff down if i still haven't
made my next video and you want more then take
a look at the ray tracing in one weekend series as
i mentioned we will be following this not like a
one-to-one mapping because i am going to introduce
a lot of my own stuff and we are going to be
writing the code in a slightly different more
performant style however they are fantastic books
they explain everything really really well their
feature diagrams and all that i'll leave a link
to this resource in the description below i think
that's a great place to start there's also this
website called scratch a pixel now i've got my
dark reader on by the way that's why everything's
dark might not be like this on your computer don't
worry probably the same website this will be in
the description below as well this is a little
bit more advanced however it it like it's more
advanced in the way it teaches but it's also more
advanced in the actual like topics so you can see
that for example ray tracing a polygon mesh this
kind of stuff is a lot more akin to you know real
world kind of ray tracing because as good as this
rage racing in one weekend series is it's not like
necessarily the way that like a real ray tracing
renderer actually works and finally if you've done
all that and you still want more then i recommend
you pick up physically based rendering from theory
to implementation this is an absolutely fantastic
book it's also a very thick book it's very very
long it's very complicated however this is one of
my favorite books on computer graphics of all time
this has nothing to do with real-time rendering
i mean this whole series that we're doing doesn't
either i did mention it would be in real time but
i mean we're writing a ray tracer so this isn't
exactly going to be you know real-time performance
with like maximum quality it is still going to be
interactive though the scene that you actually see
on the front cover was rendered using the renderer
that you build in this book i mean it doesn't
really show you how to build a renderer however
all of the source code within this book actually
comes together to form a renderer called pbrt
which is also available on the website of this
book i'm not sponsored by this book or anything i
just really like it i'll leave an amazon affiliate
link in the description below another great way
to support the channel in this series but yeah
in terms of like resources for ray tracing and
rendering and stuff like that that's definitely
up there that's pretty much all the material i
can give you i think if you follow along with all
of that stuff you will be sweet to believe me in
fact you probably won't even need this series but
on the other hand it's one thing to kind of read
you know this stuff and another thing to put into
practice so hopefully this will still be helpful
so without further ado let's begin let's set
up our seat belts project and actually get some
pixels rendering now a couple of weeks ago i made
a video where i talked about walnut an application
development framework that i developed to make
it easier to make applications especially if they
were kind of vulcan related as you can probably
guess by now that is what we'll be using as the
base for this ray tracing series so on my github
page i have walnut itself which is this repository
over here you can take a look at that and you know
see how it works and all of that that is going to
be the base library now don't be too scared this
doesn't include absolutely everything that we
might need in fact if you look at walnut it's just
this i mean ignore the i am gooey stuff it's just
this like the actual code that is already included
here is really really bare bones that's the point
of all of this so don't worry we're not gonna be
calling a function called trace raise and we're
gucci like this is gonna be we are in fact going
to be learning about ray tracing in this series
i've also got this repository called walnut
app template now this is basically like the
starter pack for a walnut application you can see
that walnut itself is a sub module and this has
essentially an application that we can modify as
a starting point to create walnut applications
and in fact because it's a github template you
can actually press this use this template button
i can make a new repository called ray
tracing and over here i'm actually going
to mark it as private for now i'm going to make
it public when i release the actual video that
i'm making i didn't really talk about this
but all of the code from like each episode
of this series is going to be available for
free on github okay that's pretty much it create
repository from template i've actually never done
this before so i hope this works and there we go
we've literally it's kind of like we've forked it
you can see it says generated from however like
this is not i guess this isn't like a fork it's
just like a starting point essentially a template
so once we've done that we're going to go to a
directory on our computer open up a command prompt
and you will of course need git installed for this
we're going to recursively clone that repository
that we've just made this shouldn't really take
too long because walnut isn't particularly big
now while this is actually happening the only
real other piece of software you'll need installed
is visual studio 2022 now i highly recommend
that you use 2022 if you can that's what all
the project files by default will generate into
and aside from that you are also going to need
to have the vulcan sdk installed i'll also leave a
link to that in the description below okay so this
is what the root of the repository looks like
all you have to do is go into scripts and run
setup.bat once that has run you can see we
have this walnut app dot solution file you
should be able to open that and see that we've
got basically our project as a quick test i'm
just going to hit f5 to build and run it and
you can see we get our basic walnut example now
all of that's great however i'm actually going to
delete everything we've just done because i don't
actually want it to be called walnut app i'm
going to call it like ray tracing or something
like that if we open up the premake 5.0 file in
the root of the repository this is where we can
actually choose like a name for all of this so i'm
going to call this ray tracing maybe we need like
another code name like what's another not that
we get like a cashew or something i don't know
if you guys have a suggestion for a name for this
project let me know in the comments below for now
i'll just call it ray tracing really boring but
it makes sense i guess i'm going to basically just
set the workspace straight racing start project
ray tracing and include ray tracing now since i am
including ray tracing i'm going to have to rename
this walnut app directory to ray tracing and that
additionally also has a pre-made 5.0 file where
i also need to basically call it ray tracing
that is it as far as i'm aware that's that's
all we have to do let's just delete these bin
directories and all that stuff and we'll rerun
setup.bat now we have a ray tracing solution
this is still like a the deleted walnut app
solution we won't save that we'll just open the
ray tracing solution now it's called ray tracing
this is still called walnut app i can rename it to
ray tray actually we'll keep it as well not out
because that's what it is and then we'll just hit
f5 you can see it now runs now let's talk about
how we can customize this and actually render
something so step one is this is basically the
normal kind of walnut entry point the only thing
that we probably need to be concerned about at
this point is maybe the title i'm going to call
this ray tracing now whether or not we want like a
file menu maybe we don't maybe we don't want that
menu bar but for now i'll just leave it there and
we have a we have two windows we have that this
diam gui demo window and this hello window this
is all dockable and we can additionally drag these
out so it's just a really great starting point
honestly however we want to be able to actually
render pixels so what do we do now what you're
actually seeing here like this entire window
this is all rendered using vulcan so if we want to
render like a custom image really all it's going
to be is an actual vulcan image whose pixels we
can directly set instead of like loading a texture
or an image file from your computer and then like
displaying it here we're going to be generating
that data ourselves and then sending it to the gpu
so that it can actually render it on our screen
now this does sound a little bit wasteful and
i mean it is right because what we're doing is
we're generating the data we're actually running
all the algorithms on the cpu in c plus plus
and then we're sending it to the gpu why not
just run those algorithms on the gpu that's what
we will eventually get to because that is so much
faster than running it on the cpu and we will see
throughout the course of this series why exactly
that is the case so if we get out of this what i'm
going to do is show you guys how to actually load
up an image or rather create an image that we're
going to be able to set the data of our cells so
i'm just going to call this image now you it is a
walnut image however what i'm going to do in this
cpp file is just type in using namespace walnut
because everything is really going to be kind of
from the walnut api here now this begin window
i'm going to change it to be our settings and this
button is going to be a button called render if we
press this button that's when i want to be able
to actually render an image so this is going to
call a function called render this video is going
to be quite basic when i get too deep into like
application architecture or anything we will do
that later but not today now when we hit render
if we do not have an image so if the image is
null then we're going to create the image and
we're going to do that by just assigning it to
sct make shared image and then we have a bunch of
parameters that we're going to take in with height
format and data optionally so the width and height
this brings us to what on earth is our width and
height well what we're going to do is we're going
to make another window called viewport so this
is going to be i'll get rid of that demo window
this is going to be our actual viewport that's
where we're going to see our rendered scene
whatever size this is which we don't really know
we're actually going to make a couple variables
here called viewport width and viewport high we're
going to ask i'm gui if we do get content region
available dot x and dot y here we'll be able to
actually get that width and height from i'm gui
now these are floats i don't really want to store
them as floats though i'll store them as un32ts
width equals zero by default height equals zero
i'll call it viewport width and viewport height
just so this extra clear so these variables will
now be how big this viewport kind of panel or
window is in pixels so this is obviously the size
that we're going to use to actually make our image
now what happens if the panel resizes if we
actually resize this window we need to recreate
this image when we hit render probably i wouldn't
re-retrace like the whole scene if we resize it
accidentally or whatever we want to explicitly
do that by hitting render so that's where this
comes in so we not only recreate the image if
it's null we're also going to recreate it if
viewport width does not equal the image width so
image.getwith or viewport heights does not equal
image get high so if that is the case we will
resize it to the new kind of viewport width and
height the format for now we're just going to use
image format rgba we will eventually move to like
using 32-bit floats and all that stuff so that
we can get some like high dynamic range i almost
feel the need to like just be like guys we're
going to do this really exciting thing later like
you'll see i'm not going to reveal any more
secrets from this series you're just going to have
to stick with it now what about the actual buffer
of pixel data we need to also create that so let's
go ahead and create this buffer here called image
data i'll just have it assigned to now by default
move it up here and so what's going to happen is
first of all when we because remember this is not
only happening if images null it also happens
if we actually resize the viewport so we want
to first of all delete the old image data if it's
null this will not do anything and that's totally
fine and then we want to reallocate it so we're
going to just type in new uin32t and it's going
to be viewport width times viewport heights now
these are already un32ts they're not like un8ts
right so they're not just bytes they're actual
32-bit integers 32 bits of course is the size of
the rgba format each channel here gets one byte so
that gives us four bytes 32 bits so we don't need
to like multiply this by four or whatever to get
it to be like the actual size and bytes these are
already 32-bit integers now let's go ahead and
actually fill this image data buffer with some
data and then we're going to just send like this
buffer to the gpu so that we can actually see it
so i'm just going to write a little for loop here
i equals zero i is less than viewport width times
height so we're going through all of the
pixels and i'm going to set image data i
equal to maybe we'll just start off with like
pink with magenta so this is actually in like an
abgr format meaning that these bytes over here are
the alpha channel this is the blue channel this is
the green channel and this is the red channel
if you read it from like right to left then it
you can see that it's the rgba format once we've
done that we can set that data by calling image
set data and what this is going to do is actually
upload this to the gpu okay the last thing that we
really have to do is actually display the image
so at the moment we're not rendering anything
right so we're going to call i am gui image and
then we're going to give it the descriptor set
of the image maybe i'll change the walnut api so
it's a little bit more clear and the size this is
the size in floats is going to be image get width
and float image get height and that's pretty much
it now obviously if image is null which it will be
for like the first few frames until we hit render
this is going to crash so we're going to
check to see if we actually have an image
to display and if we do then we're going to render
it as an i'm gui image within that viewport window
so i don't know if i've done everything correctly
but let's just hit f5 and we'll see what we get
so first up i want to actually kind of set up the
layout you'll only really have to do this once and
then it'll be saved into the imgui.ini file so if
we just dock settings maybe to the right over here
and then we'll grab our viewport dock it into the
middle this is kind of the look that i'm going for
at the moment and then if we hit render hopefully
we'll see this which is basically this kind of
just pink image now there is something that i want
to kind of clean up a little bit and that is this
border that you kind of see here around the image
that's really really easy to fix all we have to
do is before we actually begin the window we just
need to push a style var and this is going to be
i'm going style vr window padding and we're going
to set it to i am vec200 and since we've pushed it
once the window ends we're gonna pop it so pop
style var if we run that again and i hit render
you can see now it kind of fills that entire kind
of space now if i resize this and make it bigger
you can see that it doesn't stretch the image or
anything because we're actually using the images
width and height when we rendered the imgui
image if we use the viewport width and height
it would actually stretch it i don't really want
that so that's why the image isn't stretching and
if we hit render again you can see it kind
of renders using that new kind of area that
we have if i make it smaller it'll also render
presumably in that kind of smaller space now how
about something a little bit more exciting well
at the moment the image is going to be the same
all the time however let's add like a little bit
of randomness and we will need randomness when it
comes to ray tracing as well so we'll include
the walnut random class over here and then i'm
just going to set this to be random u int so this
is going to give us like just a random unsigned
integer however this is going to be fully random
across like all the rgba channels i don't want
the alpha channel to actually be random i'd
rather just have that be one so that we can
actually see something all the time so if i just
go ahead and or equals this image data by ff0000
that's going to just add in those kind of bytes
it's not going to add them but it's going to set
the kind of most significant bytes here to just
be 255 right or most significant bytes which
is the alpha channel so once i've done that
let's hit f5 i mean you don't have to do that
you'll still see stuff it's just going to
look a bit more solid with the alpha being
one and you can see if i hit render we get this
image that's going to presumably be different
every time it's going to be super important
to see how long these renders take as well so
what i want to do is actually just use
a timer over here you can include that
um by including walnut timer and then at the end
of this i'm going to set the last render time
to be timer dot elapsed milliseconds and we're
going to make that float over here set it to zero
and display it probably under well let's just
do it maybe above the render button i'm going
text last render last render 0.3 f maybe
ms for milliseconds and last render time
so if we go ahead and run that if i hit render
you should now see how long it actually takes
now you might be freaked out i mean why is that
taking 62 milliseconds most of it is actually
going to be the random number generation but also
we are in a debug build right we've we're in debug
debug is very slow if we switch to release and
run this you'll see that it will be significantly
faster okay let's hit render and you can see it's
like seven milliseconds or five milliseconds not
very fast i mean if you think about like a typical
frame budget of 60 fps for a game this is like a
third which is kind of worrying but there's a lot
of reasons for that and we will get into them as
the series goes on now finally five milliseconds
is still kind of an interactive frame rate so
why don't we try rendering this every single
frame so what i'm going to do is just basically
just add render to the online gui render function
so this obviously gets called every frame so that
now this will also be called every frame let's see
if that even works you can see five milliseconds
obviously per frame and we have an actual kind of
real time beautiful renderer thank you guys for
watching hope you enjoyed this very first episode
of the ray tracing series next time we're going to
take a look at how to actually render like an
object when we rendering a sphere maybe a sky
kind of background something a little bit more
interesting and tangible than just this kind of
noise in the meantime i'll have a link to this
ray tracing repository in the description below
definitely download it run it on your computer
make sure that it works and that way you'll be
able to follow along with the series really well
if you enjoyed this video and you're excited for
this series definitely hit the like button also
leave your thoughts in the comment section below
make sure you check out brilliant using my link
in description below to brush up on your mouth
gonna be very very important for this series and
i will see you guys in the next episode goodbye
you